♪ ♪ ♪
- Les journées de Francis Legei
commencent très tôt.
Cela fait maintenant 26 ans
qu'il se lève à l'aube pour
patrouiller la savane,
sauvegarder la faune.
Il fait partie deieieieiers
gardes forestiers de l'histoire
du Kenya et a dévoué sa vie
à la protection des animaux
sauvages.
L'homme connaît la brousse
comme le fond de sa poche.
Les girafes et les éléphants
n'ont plus aucun secret
pour lui.
Il connaît leurs habitudes.
Il sait où et quand les trouver.
Clairement, le sanctuaire
de Kimana, au pied
du célèbre mont Kilimandjaro,
est le royaume des animaux.
Il accueille des troupeaux
de zèbres, de girafes,
des autruches, des buffles;
des populations de bêtes
eseseses globalement en hausse.
Le nombre d'éléphants,
par exemple, a augmenté
de 12 % au Kenya au cours
des sept dernières années.
Une très bonne nouvelle
pour un pays dont le tourisme
dépeenenenentiellement de
l'industrie des safaris.
(barrissement)
Des chiffres dont Francis Legei
tire une grande fierté.
Un succès indéniable,
le résultat d'une politique
de conservation musclée
et d'une lutte sans merci
contre le braconnage.n n n n kit
se vend 5000 $ au marché noir.
La corne de rhinocéros,
elle, vaut 12 fos.s.s.s.
Un kilo de défense d'éléphant
se vend 5000 $ au marché noir.
La corne de rhinos,os,os,os,
elle, vaut 12 fois plus.
(en langue étrangère)
♪ ♪ ♪
Alors, pour Francis
et ses hommes, impossible
de baisser la garde.
Leur combat contre
les braconniers est capital.
Sans eux, bienspèspèspèspèces
risquent de disparaître.
Les rhinocéros noirs, ici,
sont particulièrement menacés.
(en langue étrangère)
Il s s s suivis à la trace.
(soupir)
- It's fresh...
- Leurs déjections
sont examinées à la loupe.
(en langue étrangère)
Chaque élément d'information
est soigneusement
noté et rapporté.
Ils sont tellement rares
que le seul moyen de les voir,
c'est grâce à un réseau de
caméras de surveillance.
(bip)
(en langue étrangère)
Les communications radio
encryptées, les caméras de
surveillance et la localisation
en temps réel par GPS...
- These are all our assets.
- ... autant d'armes nouvelles
qui ont transformé le travail
des gardes-chasse.
Des outils technologiques qui
ont surtout changé le rapport
de forceurururur faveur.
♪ ♪ ♪
Au fil des ans, les gardes-
chasse de Big Life ont ainsi
arrêté près 0 0 0 0 personnes.
Des centaines ont fini derrière
les barreaux avec des peines
de plus en plus sévères.
Certains de ces braconniers
repentis oeuvrent maintenant
activement à protéger
les an
- Good boy!
- C'est le cas
de Nicholas Mutinda,
chef de l'unité canine.
- Down!
- L'ancien criminel est
aujourd'hui un atout précieux
pour les gardes-chasse.
(vrombissement)
L'ONG patrouille en permanence
son territoire du haut des airs
pour suivre les déplacements
des animaux et essayer
de repérer des braconniers.
Mais selon Francis, le vrai
secret de la réussite dans
la lutte contre lennnnnnnnage,
c'est l'appui des populations.
♪ ♪ ♪
Francis ne cache pas sa fierté;
une bataille a été remportée.
Mais la guerre, il le sait,
est loin d'être terminée.
Car le marché pour les produits
du braconnage est mondial,
seule une réponse collective,
selon lui, permettra de
ve b b b bout de ce fléau.